you broke the internet a couple weeks
ago by posting this photo uh you and
Arnold Schwarzenegger carving pumpkins
together oh my God I'm doing a reality
show and I gave him a call and says yeah
can I come over he goes yeah come on
over I'll bring my donkey you can pet it
I come over and there are these fuzzy
things in his office after we do our
little
talking he goes you want to carve a punk
Chicago
and he goes like pumpkin and the
pumpkins up here then it's like knives
and some guy bringing knife I mean he's
got it's unbelievable choreographed
crazy these aren't like Uncle carving
knives you know when I saw this knife I
go
um it's home team yeah we had a pumpkin
carving contest and I'm glad to say
that I went down got the head off both
eyes and nose the mouth done before he
got one eyeball
that's what I'm talking about